[Music]
in full of regrets news submitted by I
love Amazon Prime
oh yeah most Americans feel guilty about
their spending habits and hide their
purchases from friends and family what
what do you mean hide though like I
don't think I've ever seen a friends
like bank statement what does that mean
why I say just a package is like like
the freebie hide the packages yeah like
as soon as it comes in they're like oh
[ __ ] I didn't see anything
yeah yeah the Steep ever go what's that
new thing opening so I get a package
almost every day cuz I go yeah cuz I
just like I like presents okay and so
like like it'll be like hangers or
whatever like it'll just be like little
things but they'll be on different days
and anytime Steve gets a package I get
really upset what I want to be the only
one getting packages so every time why
does this do it to your names like are
you gonna open it so like I like the
duck good the door will knock my much
and then they'll be a package and I'll
be like I got a package it's mine it's
my package it's nice for me only I only
get packages only me and then if I see a
package and it's to Steve I go wait only
me get packages only and then I take it
to the garbage
what is he order I feeling he doesn't
order by does it so the other day no
even worse so he got a package yesterday
and I was like oh no this isn't for me
it's only me get packages only me he's
like no no no no no I just read into a
game family no me only and then he's
like open it and it was for me he bought
me a thing to help me with my light and
my really [ __ ] cute I was like [ __ ]
you don't you like it when you order
[ __ ] and you forgot what it was it was
only a couple days ago they're like that
been wanting this book oh yeah and I
ordered it so does this like you want
one day shipping I'm like no give it to
me in a week when I forget
surprise me myself alright so this here
there was this poll that was conducted
by one poll on behalf of first one
portage man and so they found that the
average person spends over $200 a month
on things they later regret and so that
equals more than two thousand four
hundred dollars a year on purchases that
we regret I don't think I've ever
regretted a purchase and you can always
send it back I've never done that cuz
I'm too lazy thank oh no I know they're
saying else in the back I love it
you like sending things back yes I love
it huh maybe if it was like I
accidentally keep spending 2,000 extra a
month like then it's like wow that's
like kind of kind of 200 is a lot of new
bad is unnecessary
if 200 is just like that's like you went
out to dinner twice they probably don't
live in LA where it's hella expensive
everything here's like triple double the
rest of the world and [ __ ] that's true
yeah III think yeah I mean like 200
bucks I've just imagine you don't want
to wait 200 bucks every month that's a
lot I guess what what's they're buying
to like I guess I would regret it if I
bought like $200 worth of cat oh yeah
what is it like oh this one's cute but
this one's cute but this one's cute I'm
like oh man was $200 well [ __ ] I do get
about the top impulse buys number one is
clothing number two food number three
old shoes how do you regret like yeah me
snacks yeah I regretted that [ __ ]
meal that we had when we all went to go
eat some sushi after comic-con yeah that
was a regret or if you buy Italy or if
you're looking for the deal all the time
and you buy like 12 bags of flamin hot
cheetos when you only needed one or
something or like when you're at the
grocery store and you're shopping hungry
you end up buying a lot of food there
you're like I don't regret any of that
so then the next one is three is shoes
for is drink five is jewelry six is big
ticket technology seven is small ticket
technology
eight books nine videogames ten tickets
to events eleven apps and twelve
magazine apps I would regret yeah for
sure oh yeah that's like not fun
magazines would be number one regret
maybe it's one of those things to get
trapped into it like ad this magazine
for free for the first three months
again about the three months that's her
I know they still did that yeah do four
in like fourteen magazine place of
sadness honestly cuz they try to give
those things away like because they're
those businesses can be doing well they
will like include a magazine
subscription with like certain purchases
so like you order something online it's
like the little checkbox to get you to
join a magazine subscription you forget
about and then next year you're charged
a $9.99 for Glamour magazine you know
that's that's actually what ended up
happening to us so when we last moved
Casey made sure to subscribe to take EMU
we're not charging you anything unless
you want to go to our patreon there's a
link in the description box for that
uncensored stuff baby censored yeah you
see bunch of cities that go now what
subscribing is for free so go ahead and
do it now yep we won't charge you like a
magazine so my magazine charging story
is that Casey was in charge of when we
were moving to tell the the post office
people like eight removed that should be
free it is free I think yeah it's a
Dollar Tree
okay maybe like a dollar like super mail
forwarding yeah like like really really
reasonable but he ends up telling me
like hey yeah so I changed a address but
man it was really expensive I forgot how
much he said it was but it was like 25
bucks or something like that something
crazy so I was just like what the heck I
think it's free here like a dollar and
then so we look into it and then we find
out that that service was like a fake
USPS thing
[Music]
we're like we got all these
subscriptions to magazines but like I
don't remember I just know man it makes
me suck like we got no anytime I'm in
the [ __ ] we try we almost had it I'm
always like it takes me like three
minutes to flip through an entire mangas
I'll touch those things you want me sick
people flip through those magazines I
think about that every time I look at it
and they're all crinkled they're kind of
like wet looking like they used to be
wet in the intro you know what I love
looking through when you get on a flight
and before your screen could actually
work you know you take out that magazine
yeah it takes you like three minutes to
flip through it and you put it away and
then they're like the throw-up direction
right now they have the they always have
their like it's like a Travel Magazine
oh I was thinking SkyMall mm-hmm cuz
that used to be dope yeah there's always
two ones the SkyMall no ones like some
fake travel oh yeah
that's written by the airline I like I
like how they tell you like what you
should be doing like are you uh are you
like a influencer or like you know that
you have different lifestyles and then
they have different options for that
city like if your food oh yeah here like
thank you you could do this if you're
like outdoorsy do this Steve's always
like the bar please bar but yeah go back
to this so there may be the top impulse
spend regrets
so the previous list was the top impulse
buys was prostitution in there what's
the difference between buying and
spending me are you spending on your
buyers no so it's uh
so it's impulse buys and then impulse
maybe regret like crying regrets I guess
okay so number one is clothes I don't
need to is ordering in food or drinks
three big-ticket technologies forest
shoes five is small ticket technology
six is vacation
seven video games eight loaning / giving
money what nine a fat guy toast loaning
ya regret yeah impulse impulsive regret
oh and then 10 is right share apps I'm
like don't you need a ride how is that
an impulse and then why do you regret it
but other cities have a public
transportation pricing
oh yeah that's like nice shuttle we
can't relate like New York yeah it's
been in fact it's more inconvenient to
uber lyft in New York then to just take
the subway yes yeah because you have so
many one ways to so if you find a car
that's near you there's a good chance
they're gonna have to go all the way
around the block and try to be going the
direction they're already going to yeah
if you go up and down actually there's a
deal where you can get like kind of like
a rideshare thing where you get it
cheaper if you're just going up that a
new so it could be a lot cheaper of an
uber but at that point you might as well
just go in so yeah um reasons for
purchase embarrassment number one it was
too much money too much you sex products
number two I thought they'd laugh at me
number three it didn't fit curb laugh at
you number four it was a private
purchase at 16 yeah sex toys number five
it didn't look as advertised number six
I already regretted the purchase ha like
as they're buying it they're like I
regret
do you guys have those like must be nice
friends no you are yeah but there must
be nice tight friends yeah like like
let's say you come over and since their
life sucks and enjoy like oh you bought
that new dining table how much you need
tell them and you're like oh much money
and it makes you feel bad I'm like well
it's your fault you're poor
but try to shame you and to be I like to
shame you for your closet size because I
want it 90% of it is because I want it I
like three pairs of jeans and all barber
must be nice oh yeah element must be
nice people I like that's like all the
Mexicans I know in my life
oh that's topics do you have makeup
coming from like a joking place not like
real like I [ __ ] ate you must be nice
like it's not like that but have you
ever been around like people that you
knew at a different time in your life
and like rolled up in your nice house
car and then then like not embarrassed
that's what I first thought this was
gonna be kind of shame you've not that I
feel like embarrassed but like there's
certain bags that I may have recently
purchased I like maybe my mom doesn't
need to know that I own this you didn't
like I don't need her to know that I'm
spending like an extravagant amount of
money I got a Honda Civic Hybrid like a
lectured or maybe somebody's about to
ask me for some money for the loan know
what you do is you buy a Rolex before
she says anything that's what I did I
don't like ask for I don't feel bad but
there's definitely certain people where
I would like if I know I'm gonna be a
certain place I would dress down but
maybe like take my watch off oh of
course
yeah when I travel it's like I'm gonna
be on the go there's no point for this
and there might be areas that I'm not
too familiar with I don't want to go be
a target or you just wanna make them
feel bad yeah they're my friends I
flaunt a hundred percent because I want
to be a testament of like we could be
losers at the same time and I'm gonna
Rico both be better but it's your choice
that you didn't come up with me I hate
going to his house cuz he has like this
gold this big gold statue and he makes
us like rub its head all the time he's
like look it's real gold and then as
soon as we go in there he has like this
velvet rope I mean a robe and it has all
his rings on and he has two watches on
each Ridge Joe diamond and Christmas
like your watch like you're chewing I'll
sit at home you've been to Joe's house
yeah without bark must be nice yeah
sorry one day you'll be rich enough to
come I just don't want you to infect me
with your brokenness futures your dad
use this video a Honda Civic girl a
Honda Civic Hybrid must have a hybrid
save a lot of money on gas